[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance dragged in front of a
microphone like a nine-year-old
playground bully forced to apologize to
his victim mumbling a few platitudes
with the same petulance with which he
finally shut up about birtherism after
five years of pushing it
Trump finally said something about
racism and hate and he said nothing of
substance about Charlottesville and he
said nothing of substance about Heather
hire and he said nothing about domestic
terrorism he said nothing the President
of the United States has lost any moral
authority he may have ever had to
comment further on terrorism domestic or
international at home or abroad further
the President of the United States is at
least is at best indirectly responsible
for the domestic terror attack at
Charlottesville Virginia on Saturday and
for whatever comes next
with his weakness his imbecility his
racism his cowardice his pandering his
blindness his tone deafness his
immorality his hypocrisy
his wreaking failure his false
equivalence between terrorist victims
and terrorists his nauseating claim of
violence on many sides on many sides and
now his tardiness Donald Trump is for
all intents and purposes a sympathizer
and apologist and practically an
accessory after the fact to neo-nazi
domestic terrorism his dog whistles of
support for the terrorists were
immediate it took however until the
third day for his boilerplate statement
to acknowledge not all sides were
equally at fault and that statement
lasted for minutes as the shock has
registered of scenes ripped from the
German street marches of the 1930s and
others from the Isis vehicle terrorism
of 2016 and 2017 scenes playing not in
Nuremberg nor
but in America in Virginia in
Charlottesville on and near the campus
of the university which Thomas Jefferson
created as three Americans died and at
least 34 more were injured Donald Trump
has still said and done nothing to
contradict this conclusion he is for all
intents and purposes a neo-nazi domestic
terrorist sympathizer this rally named
by the hate groups who participated in
it quote unites the right unquote was
praised by the former leader of the Ku
Klux Klan who in attendance at it said
quote we're going to fulfill the
promises of Donald Trump that's what we
believed in that's why we voted for
Donald Trump the pathetic March at the
University of Virginia included several
participants wearing trump make America
great again caps Trump deliberately
chose to not condemn nor even repudiate
the support of these cowards and any
others like them the president's first
reactions to the rally were so vague
so tepid so meaningless so reeking of
praising by faint damnation
Charlottesville said that the neo-nazi
Richard Spencer of the white power group
the National Policy Institute retweeted
Trump on Saturday and actually asked if
Trump had just denounced the anti-racist
counter-protesters the president's
second and third reactions to the rally
including his childish statement before
the cameras on Saturday were so vague so
tepid so meaningless and began so
reeking of praising by faint damnation
that the founder of the neo-nazi site
the daily stormer wrote triumphantly
there was virtually no counter signaling
of us at all he refused to even mention
anything to do with us when reporters
were screaming at him about white
nationalism he just walked out of the
room these creatures can and will ignore
Trump's too little too late for minutes
the terrorist vehicle attack was
allegedly conducted by James Alex Fields
jr. whose own mother told The Associated
Press she knew he was going to a rally
and quote I thought it had something to
do with Trump James
Alex Fields jr. marched in
Charlottesville with the racist group
Vanguard America for nearly a decade the
political party now led by Donald Trump
insisted that those who would not call
Isis and related groups quote radical
Islamic terrorists were minimizing and
enabling those terrorists last September
19th Trump himself said quote anyone who
cannot name our enemy is not fit to lead
this country on day three
Trump has still deliberately chosen to
not condemn nor even name the neo-nazi
domestic terrorists our enemy
therefore by his own words and in
actions for all intents and purposes
Trump is minimizing and enabling those
terrorists and he is not fit to lead
this country in the to dreadful years
since he declared his candidacy Donald
Trump has condemned the Pope he has
condemned the CIA he has condemned the
FBI he is condemned Hillary Clinton he
is condemned Barack Obama he is
condemned John McCain he is condemned
Mitch McConnell he has condemned all
legitimate news organizations from
Univision to Fox News he is condemned to
attorneys general his acting Attorney
General his deputy attorney general he
has condemned random citizens ranging
from the fashion model Molly Sims to the
actor Brandon Victor Dixon to the
athlete Ronda Rousey to me he is
condemned Germany he has condemned
Mexico he's condemned Chicago he has
condemned terrorism when it was
terrorism and he has condemned terrorism
when it was not proven to be terrorism
he has had since Saturday afternoon to
condemn domestic terrorists here in
America he has had since Saturday
afternoon to specifically condemn those
at Charlottesville
he has condemned none of them six of
trumps rivals for the Republican
nomination called this what it was and
quickly used terms like white
nationalists and domestic terrorism Fox
News wondered why Trump wouldn't label
it domestic
ISM Drudge build it as make America hate
again a hockey team whose logo was
appropriated by some of the neo-nazis
immediately threatened legal action the
company that makes the tiki torches that
the marchers carried said it was deeply
saddened and disappointed we do not
support their message or the use of our
products in this way but in the moment
this Trump could bring himself to speak
only of quote hatred bigotry and
violence on many sides many sides to
speak only and in mainly of how he wants
to study the situation in
Charlottesville he could speak only and
completely consistently with all of the
dog whistles to the fascists and the
neo-nazis and the racist which peppered
his presidential campaign of how we must
quote cherish our history
an anonymous spokesperson later lied the
Trump's criticism of victims and
perpetrators alike somehow clearly
included a condemnation of the
terrorists another aide claimed Trump
had not wanted to dignify even the
generic term white nationalists even
though less than a month ago
Trump devoted an entire long political
rally to the gang called ms-13 and he
has mentioned that group by name
endlessly finally on the third day he
gave Nazis and racists four minutes
Donald Trump is not responsible directly
for the acts of domestic terrorism at
the neo-nazi attack in Charlottesville
Virginia over the weekend he is
responsible for that after the fact he
has cleared the path for domestic
terrorists to feel empowered to do what
they want to do in this country on
Saturday when asked by reporters for
more when asked for something he walked
away Donald Trump is a clear and present
danger to the safety of the citizens of
the United States of America as if this
were not enough he has also acted in the
interests of the Russian government he
has threatened conflict with North Korea
provoke possible nuclear conflict with
China and spoken of unspecified
military action against Venezuela his
presidency is no longer tenable and in
less than seven months he has led this
nation to such depths that there is only
one solution
the removal by any legal means of that
president immediately or failing that
the refusal of the citizens of this
nation to cooperate any longer with a
racist hateful irresponsible government
that coddles domestic terrorists and is
led by this filth Trump resists remove
peace